madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour ce premier numéro de la saison de
la voie libre voie libre en direct c'est
la rentrée et qu'elle rentrait une
rentrée à très agitée avec la mise en
place d'un gouvernement va lever la
grogne des députés socialistes disent
fondeur la ferté genou le vrai faux
suspense sur le retour de nicolas
sarkozy la chute dans les sondages de
françois hollande ou encore la montée
dans ces mêmes sondages de marine le pen
de tous ces thèmes nous allons discuter
avec eux nous inviter leurs gonds
guillaume nouveau vous êtes député
socialiste de la côte-d'or première
circonscription jean bullant ce mot
bonjour bonjour il était président de
l'ump de saône et loire avait confié
régional de bourgogne françois doz
bonjour secrétaire du parti communiste
de la nièvre est conseiller municipal à
nous hier édouard collin secrétaire
national du front national en côte d'or
cotait 1 départementale par le couple en
quarts des soldats et conseiller
municipal a dû comme bonjour à la maison
n'hésitez pas à pas de changement cette
année vous pouvez poser vos questions
directement à nos invités via notre site
internet en ce 3 point fr dont 23 france
3 point fr sur notre page facebook ou
sur twitter
#veille bourgogne ou apf 3 bourgogne à
la mort rapide d'introduction sur le
climat les général de cette rentrée
laurent grandguillaume vous sentez bien
au sein de cette majorité qui a l'air de
douter d'elle belle en ce moment fait
partie de ta liste un peu de courage
d'audace en politique
après tout on ne gagne que les combats
que l'on mène donc le contexte
économique est difficile le contexte
social même temps il faut évidemment il
faut se battre
pour suivre les raisons mais je crois
avoir un peu la petite équipe celle de
là il faut confronter les idées
maintenant il faut rester soi même et
aller de l'avant et je crois que ce sont
dans cet état d'esprit que jan koller
sur la rentrée de l'ump à l'itie est
divisée elles sont en déclin à vos
retours qu'on vient cette situation
d'abord de savoir faire la rentrée
je pense que la rentrée qui intéresse
surtout les montrer c'est le constat que
aucun engagement n'est tenu ni sur le
déficit ou sur la dette ni sur la
croissance et sur l'emploi
je crois que la rentrée se caractérise
justement par ce qu'on fait à plus ou
moins négatif quant à l'ump dont je
pense que nous y reviendrons tout au
long de l'émission ont fait part à ce
complot nicolas sarkozy a envie de
revenir maintenant probablement une
katzen jour j'aurai l'occasion de
répondre à votre question plus
précisément tout à l'heure on y
reviendra effectivement on se faisait la
gueule à la fête de l'humanité
on parle beaucoup de la 307 nouvelle
gauche de cette alternative à gauche
c'est l'avant l'objectif de la rentrée
pour à trois où le front de gauche est
partie comme la fête de l'humanité c'est
peut-être le signe d'espoir en cette
rentrée politique qui caractérise
effectivement par une très grave crise
politique démocratique
certains parlent d'une crise de régime
je pense qu'on est effectivement dans
une situation doute ou de sortir y
compris la guerre donc je le sens
dramatiser je pense que vraiment on est
dans une situation qu'il faut prendre à
bras le corps à gauche
elle tombera du ciel cette situation
elle est le résultat de choix politiques
qui sont obstinément mise en oeuvre par
le couple exécutif qui reste sourd à
toutes les alertes d'où qu'elles
viennent de toutes les familles de la
gauche donc pas de plus et rien de plus
urgent que de changer de cap c'est
l'objectif de la grande fête de
l'humanité qui s'ouvre ou se
retrouveront toutes les familles
politiques de gauche et notamment celles
et ceux qui ne veulent pas
en rabattre sur les ambitions de la
gauche dans ce pays à qui jean françois
bouche le mot dissolution ce responsable
je crois qu'aujourd'hui dans une telle
crise que l'on rit parce que le
gouvernement hollande ou valls a réussi
à combiner une crise économique une
crise sociale et une crise politique
on l'avait pas encore la crise politique
il a rajouté ça en plus on est dans une
situation qui peut s'apparenter à une
crise de régime
et je crois qu'aujourd'hui le seul moyen
pour pourront cette mauvaise dynamique
et ce pessimisme ambiant
c'est d'en revenir au peuple car le
peuple est souverain dans une démocratie
et sait mieux que quiconque qui sera le
guider vers l'avenir alors parler de
crise politique dernier en date un
casque ou un peu le monde politique
c'est la technique que l'on connaît bien
ici puisque c'est le député de la
première circonscription de ce dès lors
il a donc dû démissionner du
gouvernement deux jours après sa demie
l'assaut le vendredi où finalement il ya
un député de mont douze communes aisées
partie de ce qu'on appelait les valeurs
montantes du parti socialiste comme dit
est ce que vous sentez grammy comment
vous avez vécu cet épisode
écoutez d'abord c'est un peu ce n'est
pas ce que c'est vrai qu'on ne
s'attendait pas à ça par contre ce qu'il
faut quand même rappeler c'est qu'il ya
une loi sur la transparence qui a été
votée mais qui n'a pas été voté par
l'ump qui étaient contre cette
transparence et qui sait grâce à cette
loi transparence en fait que l'on a pu
savoir avant ne savait pas on ne sait
pas que par exemple madame et monsieur
balkany n'ont pas payé ses frais en 17
ans on saura pas elle a fait une
déclaration cet été on ne savait pas
forcément que d'autres ne paient pas
leurs impôts
moi je considère que quand on n'est pas
justement en règle avec les impôts avec
tout simplement ses obligations avec sa
responsabilité individuelle et bien on
ne devrait pas pouvoir se présenter à
des élections ce qui va de soi
donc il faut aller encore plus loin par
rapport à la transparence on a avancé
sur le cumul des mandats le non cumul
soit transparent ce sont encore aller
plus loin je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'on vous donnera confiance dans la
démocratie
il ya encore beaucoup de choses à dire
il ya encore beaucoup à faire mais sage
pour thomas thévenoud
choqué beaucoup de monde il doit prendre
ses responsabilités
et puis johnson et on a des exemples
oui sans doute mais on a des exemples
trop nombreux dans politiques même s'ils
ne sont pas représentatifs hébreu il
faut peut-être changer un certain nombre
de compagnies peel et sainte-catherine
quelques jours beaucoup de pub et là
dessus vous poser une question d'un
téléspectateur qui nous dit et je crois
qu'elle est assez révélatrice elle il
s'appelle guillaume il dit à tous je
voudrais poser les bonnes questions
y en at il un sur le plateau qui croient
encore que l'on va le croire
c'était je pense qu'effectivement la
question est tout à fait terrible et
aussi été révélatrices d'une situation
qui au fil du temps à déconsidérer la
classe politique parce qu'il ya eu à
droite comme à gauche sur le sol et dc10
qui viennent de s'écouler un certain
nombre de scandales
c'était bien sûr amplifié et repris
amplifier ce mouvement par les médias
nationaux et on arrive aujourd'hui à
cette image des politiques pour pourri
alors que l'ensemble de la classe
politique à 95 97 % sont des citoyens
qui se sont créées lire qui sont
honnêtes qui sont qui travaillent et qui
paie évidemment leurs impôts moi je
voudrais dire juste un mot pour leucate
et de nous il était assis lors de la
dernière fois lors de la dernière fois
où je suis venu ici en martyr la
dernière édition date de la dernière
édition
moi je veux pas kabyle sommes plus qu il
est nécessaire de le faire
simplement il est devant ses
responsabilités aujourd'hui c'est à lui
en son âme et conscience par rapport à
l'honneur qui se fait de son mandat de
prendre la décision mais juste pour une
boutade ont fait que le conseil général
de saône et loire avec monsieur
montebourg dépenser des fortunes des
milliers d'euros pour faire de la
communication sur le mot saône-et-loire
et bien jamais la fois d'avoir été aussi
connu est aussi mise en avant que cette
dernière semaine par les médias
nationaux que nous les journalistes
notamment de mâcon je parle d'ailleurs
si l'on patrick courtois ne ne se sent
pas un peu en situation de voir une
femme il dévalorisée par rapport aux
nouveaux rebondissements de la perte est
simplement c'est pour la beauté réalité
cet énarque
c'est vrai que le concitoyen aujourd'hui
peuvent déjà jouer 36 cette question et
sur notre site internet gg comme on ne
parlera de doute sur vous sur les élus
maintenant la question de dieu je crois
aujourd'hui qu'il dit effectivement
qu'un seul parti qui parti politique qui
incarne l'avenir et c'est le seul qui
monte dans les sondages aujourd'hui
c'est le front national c'est une
justice s'il ya des problèmes et j'en
vois en passant par le prochain avion
c'est parce que il ya eu prenable blanc
rouge sur un wagon où je veux dire même
da silva qui est première à doite donc
été connaît un vote qui seront testés à
lyon je t'avais a indiqué avoir
illégalement financé la campagne de
l'élu et donc qu'on avait mais bien sûr
mais est une réalité c'est que le front
national des kings brebis galeuses c'est
on n'a même pas besoin d'attendre les
médias ont fait ce qu'il faut pour qu'il
soit exclu aujourd'hui on a le cas
thévenoud ces exclus avoir une exclu
comme monsieur lavrilleux devrait
exclure et p on n'a plus de nouvelles
depuis ce matin ses fonctions a priori
on n'en parle plus je pense que ça sera
le même la même chose pour monsieur
était venu peuvent tout simplement parce
que le ps aujourd'hui chaque voix compte
à l'assemblée nationale parce que c'est
un gouvernement aux abois et nationale
ça dit qu'il ne comptera pas lors de ce
tour
oui mais elle voit qu'on peut quand même
dans les flammes dans le juridique
comptable on n'en voit que le maire de
langeac explosion du conseil municipal
le conseiller politique du dialogue
social de marine le pen
on peut effectivement s'attendre à de
petites communes on attend des bassins
exemple à peu près on a regardé ce qu
elles sont strueth et la liberté prise
par les médias toute la journée
j'aimerais bien que les médias pour le
coup face le même travail dans d'autres
communes notamment tenus par le ps qui
sont dans des situations dramatiques
recense notamment pour le calmer on a
appris le front national a pris la
commune du pontet dans le sud de la
france
une petite commune il ya peu il ya peu
d'habitants 50 millions d'euros de des
50 millions d'euros pour une petite
commune
maintenant je cours au c'est pour dire
un petit peu le plus vite la situation
on parle par exemple de fait justement
parce que le maire va fermer un centre
social il va mettre dix personnes à la
porte puisque mon père de rampeau donc
entre effectivement en france aucun plan
social
un autre débat
je sais qu'il a confiance en son nouvel
épisode lamentable de la crise
démocratique convient et je pense que
les échanges
on a là sont propres et d'inverser la
tendance de laval on a appris au passage
qu'il était possible de payer ses impôts
pendant trois ans alors qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des murs en ce moment même il ya
des milliers de personnes qui font la
queue
la porte des centres des impôts parce
qu'ils ne sont pas capables est ce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas payer le troisième
tiers provisionnel voilà ça c'est la
vraie vie c'est la vraie vie et ça pose
quand une question de son ca pose la
question de comment les partis
politiques sont exxon ou choisissent
leur candidat
voilà comment est il possible
effectivement un parti de gauche comme
le parti socialiste présente des cas
vise à aider les jeunes ou aux élections
voilà il faut présenter des gens du
monde du travail
voilà c'est ce que en tout cas au parti
communiste on a toujours fait car un
seul ouvrier à l'assemblée nationale
c'est mon camarade par patrice carvalho
qui est venu en bleu de travail et la
dernière fois pour montrer un petit peu
comment le monde du travail a représenté
à l'assemblée nationale ça fait le buzz
voilà marie george buffet jean claude
berri andré chassaigne
il est principal d'un petit collège
rural dans le puy-de-dôme ça c'est les
gens qui savent comment vivent les gens
voilà je pense que la question de fond
elle est renvoyée aux partis politiques
donc comment comment de l'allier avec la
mention vidéo aujourd'hui ne vous fait
plus confiance parce que vous les
arrêtera au national ces postes on voit
bien effectivement pas sur le monde
ouvrier souris collaveri brûlant
notamment nommé front national
effectivement mon administration faut
pas se réjouir la situation qu'on vit
aujourd'hui à ne pas s'en réjouir je
vous rassure c'est pour ça qu'on propose
des solutions très clair aux français le
repli sur soi vous défendez tellement
les ouvriers qu'en fait vous n'expliquez
pas comment vous ferez de mal pour les 1
salarié sur quatre en france qui vivent
de l'exportation dans nos entreprises
c'est terminé
vous vous n'expliquez pas cela donc en
fait votre politique ce que vous
défendez la préférence nationale
la préférence à semaine n'est pas la
préférence sociale en fait ce que vous
défendez
c'est tout simplement la remise en cause
aussi de la compétitivité de nos
entreprises c'est justement demain à
salarié sur quatre en france avec pour
l'exportation qui seront en difficulté
mais ça vous n'expliquez pas parce que
vous restez justement dans la caricature
permettent de répondre à monsieur louis
et apprendre l'exportation par exemple
est ce que vous croyez sincèrement que
c'est parce qu on remettrait des
frontières en france qu'on exporterait
plus on exportait plus avant la zone
euro monsieur c'est une réalité
je vous rappelle à titre indicatif que
95% des pays dans le monde ont des
frontières exporte bien sûr massivement
les droits de douane des plus élevés au
monde sont en chine c'est le pays qui
est le premier exportateur mondial où ça
les réalités économiques
est ce que pendant dix ans pardon
politique industrielle pendant dix ans
entre pays donc forcément la
compétitivité des entreprises s'est
dégradée ou dix ans depuis c'est depuis
35 ans la chose est en train d'écrire et
35 ans et vous vous devriez savoir on ne
peut pas dire clairement veux pas parler
on va préserver vos emplois industriels
on est au vin ouvert aux vents de la
mondialisation ce n'est pas possible
alors le monde à gazon qu'est-ce que ça
produit soit les français n'attendent
pas de baisse de salaire soit à une
casse dans une casse de notre système
social notamment de protection sociale
c'est une réalité aujourd'hui c'est soit
l'un soit l'autre pour les gouvernements
valcin à base de zinc yeux et c'est ce
qu'ils veulent mettre en place et une
prospérité on appelle ça leur austérité
vers une politique qui ne marche pas et
qui est contesté aujourd'hui par la
plupart des grands spécialistes
économiques dans le monde entier qui
contestent cette politique d'austérité
qui n'a aucun bénéfice pour les peuples
on a eu l'occasion d'en parler dans
différentes les émissions seraient
vraiment qu'on reviendra au pin up cette
rentrée notamment françois hollande qui
est très content et c'est de plus en
plus contestée des sondages assez bas
comment que expliqué c'est un peuple il
a ri té record est ce qu'il ya un relent
de daqing lescure un hollande jean bacci
pour faire en sorte qu'ils remontent à
deux comme encore monter la pente est
toujours restée alitée il ya eu aussi
deux erreurs qui ont peu de cézanne il
faut le reconnaître
en même temps une majorité qui n'est pas
suffisamment soudé quand on parle de ce
monde heures la fronde menée contre le
chômage contre les nouveaux
réactionnaires également mais dont cette
majorité qui parfois divisés comme on
attendait des bases sur les choix et
c'est normal puisque le chômage ne
baisse pas puisque la situation
économique ne s'améliore pas et bien
effectivement il ya des débats il ya des
critiques qui sont formulées et c'est la
normale c'est sain pour la démocratie
maintenant il faut tenir bon les
institutions et son solide quand on
parle de dissolution de la crise de
régime que certains veulent provoquer
une reine accepté il nous a décrété que
la gauche notamment elles demandent des
élections
d'ailleurs les autres parler des
traditions les ports par effraction
voyait un peu la philosophie qu'ils
défendent et bien non il faut continuer
à la politique pour continuer les
réformes d'ailleurs les français dans
les différents sondages dont on ne parle
pas comme celui de challenger qui est
intéressant de montre que les français
ils veulent des réponses structurelles
au cnic devant des raisons structurelles
après ya une critique par rapport à
l'exécutif par rapport à la manière dont
les choses sont faites et puis peut-être
parfois par rapport à des erreurs qui
ont pu être commises il ya peut-être
dire la rescousse de françois hollande
je sais pas si vous avez vu ça cette
semaine jean paul anciaux c'est un
déclic et une frédéric lefebvre qui a
dit arrêtons respectant deux présidents
nous avons choisi il s'insurge contre le
déferlement de haine se dit par françois
hollande il dit respecter les
institutions de sa tournée dans les pays
où nous en sommes c'est vrai que moi je
vais renoncer à croire qu'il avait
atteint le niveau de cuba continue mais
moi je voudrais simplement dire deux
choses me tournant real le représentant
du parti socialiste et ses feuilles sont
le seul mot à la bouche aujourd'hui
grâce aux institutions ça tient
quand on sait depuis monsieur mitterrand
monsieur change pas de position de solan
contre la constitution de la vème
république voulant toujours modifié
quand on sait les positions de monsieur
montebourg pour la 6ème république vous
entendent aujourd'hui vous raccrocher
aux institutions c'est quand même assez
pitoyable me semble-t-il
ça c'est un premier point pour revenir
maintenant vous reveniez amateurs c'est
votre propos et répondre
eric sicaud sur la situation du hall en
hollande il a fait toute une campagne
sur le mensonge la démagogie et la casse
de sarko quand il est arrivé au pouvoir
il a détricoté tout ce que nicolas
sarkozy en effet pour que comme quelque
chose de démarches devant jean ristat
jusqu'à la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires les salariés qui et qui
bénéficia de 13 heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées ont été outrés par ces
espaces et diffusion par monsieur
hollande
moi j'en ai rencontré plusieurs fois je
leur ai expliqué mais il vous l'avez dit
où la dcri sur la cime des rares choses
qu'il est tenu dans son programme
comment voulez vous que les que les
français notamment les françaises à
gauche puisse comprendre et derrière
pendant deux ans il n'a pris aucune
décision
tout est parti à vau l'eau aujourd'hui
je le dis dans mon propos liminaire le
déficit la dette la croissance l'emploi
tout ça et là où tu es en plus nous
sommes l'arrivée j'allais dire de du
monde occidental rapport aux situations
privé de monsieur hollande je n'en dirai
pas plus mais quand vous reprenez les
quotidiens allemands suisses hubei c'est
dramatique l'image de la voie des
questions à défiler on va beaucoup me
demandent pourquoi tant d hommes
politiques sont dans l'opposition qui
était encore il ya quelques temps ils
ont plein d'idées il les pertes quand
ils arrivent au pouvoir s'arrêter sur la
campagne de mensonges qu'aurait donné à
françois hollande françois hollande
soyons clairs à déchirer le contrat de
2012 il passe son temps à tourner le dos
aux engagements qu'il a pris lors de la
campagne de 2012 et il passe son temps à
tourner le dos aux valeurs de gauche il
avait dit qu'il lutterait contre la
finance il sait tous les jours le
contraire il avait dit qu'il ne
négocierait le traité d'idiot terre
européen il le signale à vienne ils
prêts il s'entête dans une politique
d'austérité qui compriment et qui emmène
toute l'économie
vers le bas voilà et donc il n'y a pas
de majorité politique dans le pays pour
faire cette politique là voilà il ya
même pas de majorité politique à gauche
et maintenant il ya une pile majorité
politique au sein même du parti
socialiste
une seule option monsieur hollande c'est
ce que nous nous vous disons depuis deux
ans et demi
les députés communistes ont frondeurs
depuis 2012 1 il faut changer de cap
l'austérité c'est pas la solution c'est
le problème
il faut changer de politique et c'est
possible via une majorité politique dans
le pays pour interdire les licenciements
boursiers
il ya une majorité politique on paie
l'assemblée nationale si on décide de
mettre en place un grand pôle public
bancaire de notre en place d'une
sécurité d'emploi formation de maîtres
maîtrise publique dans un secteur
stratégique
les pays étaient par game boy majorité
ya une majorité il ya une majorité rouge
rose verte disponible à l'assemblée
nationale c'est françois hollande qui
tourne le dos aux valeurs de gauche et
le peuple français de mon une chose
simplement c'est le respecte et donc la
faute de l'humanité en ce sens là vous
je me félicite qui est enfin au sein du
parti socialiste des gens qui relève un
petit peu l'oreille on les appelle les
frondeurs ont pas la cueillette des
écologistes qu'il y ait des militants
syndicaux des militants associatifs qui
voit là se rapproche et maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ensemble parce que
dans la situation actuelle le front
national commente mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait qu'est ce qu'on s'en sortir il faut
passer de la juxtaposition des critiques
à l'action commune demande une réponse
ou comme tout le reste devient une
pétition dans la caricature parce que en
matière de bilan on ne donnait pas de
leçons c'est loupé quand on voit votre
bilan franchement vous n'avez pas
descendre on est dans l'opposition on
s'oppose
posologie en un temps où je crois que
l'expression financière de l'état la
situation économique est tellement
difficile qu'il faudrait peut-être
régler un peu le niveau du débat parce
qu'en fait il s'agit de l'intérêt
national dont on parle il s'agit de
pousser français qui sont au chômage et
dans des solutions qui attendent des
solutions mais quand je vois les
caricatures on sait qu'il avait
l'habitude avec nicolas sarkozy
donc sur le fond de tempête sur le fond
il faut continuer le travail sur la
compétitivité de nos entreprises aux tpe
de nos pme et de nos entreprises en
france
arrêté sur la baisse des cotisations
pour que pour parler de ça ce sont les
cotisations déjà qui finance un système
de solidarité et donc oui il ya des
baisses de cotisations qui ont été
votées et qui s'appliqueront ensuite il
faut continuer le travail par rapport
aux mesures qui ont été prises en
direction de chômage des jeunes
notamment les emplois d'avenir les
confédérations qui se dépendant
territoire la prime qui a été votée pour
l'apprentissage des finances de
l'apprentissage il faut le relancer
c'est difficile
depuis deux ans en apprentissage il faut
commencer l'apprentissage c'est
important aussi de l'éducation gré à la
question de l'éducation et de l'école
parce que nous sommes
après la rentrée scolaire il ya eu des
postes qui ont été créés les rythmes
scolaires qui ont été mises en oeuvre
dans toutes les communes contrairement à
ce qu'on a entendu puisque certains
maires ne voulait pas appliquer la loi
de la république c'est quand même
ennuyeux et donc je crois que war on
avance c'est difficile les résultats et
bien sont attendus mais il ya donc deux
choses qui sont faites mais françoise un
premier bilan de cette semaine vous avez
peut-être ça soit pas de responsabilité
qui prévalaient pour m 40 milliards bad
aux entreprises en contrepartie de
concessions d'emploi et d'investissement
sans contrepartie aux grandes
entreprises de grandes nationales
qui va t'il équivalent au mal comme le
maximum le en termes d'entrées je pense
que n'allait pas que la poste mais c'est
la preuve que quand on met simplement
aujourd'hui je suis suis d'entreprise
mais simplement simplement aujourd'hui
je peux vous dire que je rencontre des
chefs d'entreprises bp de pme pmi qui
aujourd'hui s'opposent stade de ne même
plus sortir de salaire pour pouvoir peut
continuer à payer leurs salariés ce
moment est là aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est
ça la réalité et écouter l'an passé
s'est fait plutôt profil bas
essayer de courir toujours expliqué que
vous avez payé
vous n'avez pas réussi parce que hein
vous avez vous n'avez absolument non
vous allez difficulté dans laquelle se
trouvait la france en 2012 vous n'avez
pas joué à grand chose vous avez menti
après vous avez pris des mauvaises
décisions autour d une question concrète
monsieur est venu et 250 milliards
d'euros la dépense publique d'accord il
y en a bien un plan d'économies de 50
milliards vous faites comment c'est
contre vous à les diminuer qu'est ce que
vous allez faire comme économie et nous
alors puisqu'on les 150 milliards
détaillé moi quels sont les ordures tout
est prévu que je défendrai pas
aujourd'hui vous sera parfois c'est pour
conséquence concrètement déjà je vais
revenir à ce que nous avons fait de vie
avait prévu à savoir le la répression
d'un fonctionnaire sur deux le non
remplacement
quand je reviens que je rejoue à cela je
fais passer la compréhension mais où les
éléphants salaires de supor là on
propose à vos questions et ensuite
ensuite on peut aussi gagner énormément
avec les collectivités territoriales
vont actuellement en ligue 1
ça c'est une erreur et je suis parti
socialiste est à mettre au compte du
nombre d'entre eux n'est caché donc
vraiment et puis sport collectivités
locales
non pourquoi des oppositions 1 en
glissement n'est que mon nom pour être
qu'on peut faire en sorte aujourd'hui de
supprimer un grand nombre de postes y
compris dans les collectivités locales
avec le dit enfin nous aurons deux
heures pile aa les doublons etc
on peut faire énormément de choses et
puis il ya encore un grand nombre
d'économies qui peuvent être faites dans
certains secteurs de l'administration où
là encore administrations nationales
il ya pléthore de deux de ces décharges
sur monsieur guillaume a tort parce
qu'ils n'ont pas appliqué aujourd'hui
j'espère que le bois j'espère que les
bourguignons qui nous écoutent ont bien
compris qu'il y avait aucune différence
entre les deux parties c'est ce que vous
propose d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on le
voit très bien avec la domination par
exemple de monsieur macron qui issus de
la grande finance et la travaille chez
rothschild et se retrouve aujourd'hui
ministre dans le gouvernement dans un
gouvernement de gauche
je trouve ça particulièrement incroyable
le l'ump n'aurait pas tenu n'aurait pas
n'auraient même pas osé nommer quelqu'un
issu de chez rothschild or aujourd'hui
on se retrouve dans cette situation est
le fait est que les français sont dans
des grandes difficultés est ce la faute
uniquement de pousser 30 ans
pardon vous n'êtes toujours pas parti
social le parti d'un seul homme sociales
et le coût social pour qu'ils se sentent
puisqu'on et pouvoir la préférence
nationale à la préférence nationale reçu
c est le plus souvent vers ses
compatriotes sociale voilà monsieur à la
fête de l'humanité
ça devrait s'appeler la fête des
français parce que c'est bien beau
d'être remis pour l'humanité on va
commencer par s'occuper des français qui
sont aujourd'hui dans les plus grandes
difficultés et après on verra si on peut
aider les autres mais je crois qu'il
faut se recentre un petit peu sur
nous-mêmes s'occuper de ceux qui
souffrent chez nous est ce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un pays
où il ya plus de huit millions de
pauvres
nous leur cinquième puissance mondiale
mais il ya eu une ou deux jours
le centre social à fréjus paiement
intégral des centres sociaux le logement
social etc
ça n'est pas forcément sociale
d'ailleurs votre politique par exemple
du logement social caf et l'ump et que
pratique le ps aujourd'hui allègrement
ne résout pas les vraiment que s'il vous
plaît messieurs vicieux on va faire une
petite pause parce qu'il est midi
donc on va prendre connaissance de
l'actualité à la mi journée dans la
région
le flash aujourd'hui est présenté par
l'isère et nous on se retrouve dans cinq
petites minutes